on va s'intéresser à davos il se passe
plein de choses à propos de l'émission
notamment une histoire de trucage
rassurez vous l'inspecteur baba va tout
vous expliquer regarde chaque samedi
plus de 4 millions de téléspectateurs
passe la soirée devant le télé crochet
le plus célèbre de france
the voice lors des phases finales de ce
célèbre concours ce sont les
téléspectateurs qui votent par téléphone
pour élire le grand vainqueur
enfin ça c'est ce qu'on croyait tous en
effet manon une candidate de la saison 3
vient de lâcher une énorme bombe sur son
compte instagram la jeune fille aux
cheveux rouges annonce que l'émission de
tf1 serait truqué les résultats du télé
crochet serait tout simplement fausses
et selon manon les candidats signé par
des maisons de disques avant l'émission
aurait un sérieux avantage
pire encore certains producteurs
n'hésiterait pas à payer des centrales
d'appels pour gonfler les votes ainsi
leur poulain optimiser leurs chances
d'aller le plus loin possible dans
l'aventuré
alors qui sont ces producteurs qui
essayent de truquer le jeu ont-ils le
droit d'utiliser des centrales d'appels
et surtout nikos aliagas fréquente il
l'aimé même cabine à uv que bernard
montiel
autant de questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur baba va tenter de répondre
[Applaudissements]
les accusations de mme banon comme vous
l'avez vu l'émission de tf1 est accusé
par manon une ancienne candidate de
magouiller avec certains candidats
jusqu'à les faire gagner elle a fait
d'énormes révélations sur sa story
instagram regarde c'est parce qu'il faut
en être conscient et c'est la vérité
il existe des centrales d'appels que les
managers peuvent payer pour qu'on puisse
voter pour leurs artistes et
gratuitement
je dirais pas de nom ça sert à rien par
exemple je fais de voice mon manager
peut admettons payer dix mille euros une
centrale d'appels qui va faire qu'il ya
plein de gens qui vont pouvoir appeler
gratuitement pour voter pour moi et me
donnait des votes en plus voilà c'est
réel ça existe vous ne croyez vous ne
croyez pas vous
alors est ce qu a dit p alors a priori
c'est légal mais alors oui benjamin ça
fait des années que ça existe
malheureusement dans tous les jeux on
sait qu'il ya ceux qui sont aidées qui
mobilise des centres d'appels qui paye
pour ça ça coûte peu près 0 5 centime
d'euro si vous achetez dix mille ans
mais ça n'est pas moi je les avais dans
tous les cas soit dans votre famille et
vous ne savez pas avait pas donc vous
acheter quoi 10000 20000 20000 38 50
mille appels non pour équilibrer et est
donc ça veut dire quoi ce à dire que
quand tu faisais 56 oui tous étaient
déjà prêts pratiqués ni la vérité -
c'est je pense que c'est moi c'est moins
en moins d'enjeux sur sursis crète mais
je pense que sur cycle est évidemment il
ya ce kit renseigné conclut acheter des
appels et bien évidemment et alors
évidemment ce qui poserait problème avec
ce dossier c'est que les membres de la
production serait complètement au
courant ça c'est plus embêtant
bah oui mais ouais mais c'est normal oui
mais c'est pas une cci ziga illégal pas
à la règle du jeu
on va dire que c'est ça ta tombe pas
sous le coup d'une agression à la règle
en sais pas
gillot mais ce qu'est ce qui m'énerve
quand on l'entend valérie benjamin ça
c'est votre mauvais côté c'est la face
obscure parce que vous le dit tout et
tout le monde le sait mais non le
téléspectateurs qui regardent le voyais
tous les samedis
il le sait pas et on est révolté cela
veut dire que vos votes c'est pas le
meilleur qui gagne tout est bidonné vous
dites c'est normal c'est bidonné partout
il est bon votre bonne et installe des
[Applaudissements]
dents là dans la démagogie
moi je suis au courant j'ai ma grande
soeur je n'avais aucune idée de la
triche me révolter les spectacles les 3
d'après je m'en fous mais c'est pas de
la tribune
au final ces finales seaman il est bon
il a gagné
m kenji girac il est très bon il a gagné
non ya pas une réservation de talent
surtout une loi n'est les frérots de las
vegas sont pas gagné c'est eux qu'on
fait carrière bien évidemment que c'est
scandaleux parce que le problème c'est
que ok si c'est un show de variétés n'y
a pas de souci par contre si tu te mets
des règles et que les règles tu les
bafoue en faisant appel à ses sexy gouët
en tout cas à ses centres d'appels
évidemment que tout est faux c'est
évidemment qu'elles j'étais vachement
bien mais l année où il a été élu v e
siècle était formidable aussi peut-être
girl a pu gagner ça
pas que tricher mais en tout cas si tout
est truqué ça jette le discrédit sur
tout jean michel vous avez peut-être
médias que je bosse trop chef c'est pas
faux et j'appelle les centrales
japonaises d'après midi non voilà oui et
boulot voilà déjà lu les centres
d'appels c'est fou ça vous avez bossé là
et diana qui sont assez dubitatif sur
cette histoire sitruk ça coûte
énormément cher donc vu le marché du
marché du disque en ce moment c'est pas
marcher très florissant voilà le mot ils
disent qu ils sont très dubitatifs ça
coûterait très cher et ce moment de
l'appel dit qu'elle le facture est le
plus de 100000 euros
ce service la cia une maison disque le
leur demander voilà donc ça coûterait
très cher
ils voient pas la télé formulation la
payer les gens à essayer d'influer sur
les réseaux sociaux
faire de la propagande est ce que tous
ceux qui ont gagné avec une maison de
disques déjà six et qui disent que
beaucoup de candidats ont déjà une
maison de disques avant d'aller s'offrir
son sol et chantant mais moi j'en avais
déjà entendu parler maintenant voilà
c'est comme tous ceux qui achètent les
vues sur youtube
c'est vrai que finalement vous très
choqué par ces allégations et je suis
très choqué mais pourquoi c'est pas
sorti avant pourquoi pas une affaire là
dessus tant qu'il n'y a pas de preuves
on peut pas affirmer qu'il ya de la
triche de la fraude même chose moi il
m'a dit donc je soutiens quelqu'un ma
famille un fan club des amis on va voter
en masse pour quelqu'un est ce qu'on va
considérer ça comme de la triche jamais
sûr il ya un truc qui est sûr c'est que
le profil de la personne qui appelle est
plutôt jeune fille y voit la jeune
sophie j'imagine ça je sais ce qu'on
avait dit sur quasi ça peut amener vers
le choix qui est plutôt le beau garçon
enfin c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit c'est
ta vidéo se comprendre à ces sas que ce
que je trouve assez bon et dans cinq ans
un gros compte instagram ou twitter
quand les gros cons donc forcément ça
fais plus d'appels exactement au sel
c'est la guerre c'est le jeu c'est comme
les téléspectateurs ce qu'ils en pensent
qu'ils sont choqués ou pas les
téléspectateurs
merci suspects et les trucs échoué à 92%
ces foules mieux même si oui parce
qu'ils disent je ne dis pas les noms ça
sert à rien massat pardon mais accusé
comme ça sans abri s'achète le rêve
ce que je trouve choquant c'est d'être
debout sur des fauteuils comme sa
voisine ont le plus question c'est
madame madame turpin qui est chez elle
qui téléphonent elle se rend compte que
son voeu qu'il vaut rien c'est ça ce que
garda il ya dix mille qui valent cos et
c'est ça qui doit trouver un vrai truc
voilà ça c'est tout les gens qui votent
se dit bâton terrain et ils n'ont rien
vu d'aussi est floue et tient à la
maison et y est floue mais c'est sûr
attention
[Rires]